edge rushers who have availability
questions who have signed free agent
contracts this off season alton smith
genevieve clowney yannick and gaque and
gawkway signing with the ravers uh the
the raiders excuse me and clowny with
the browns which doesn't belong and why
i'd say alden smith because in my
opinion aldon smith is going to give
more production to the seahawks than
either of those other two guys
uh will give their team i think aldon
smith was one of the uh kind of
feel-good stories about the season last
year in dallas and i think especially if
you got carlos dunlop and alden smith
two veteran guys who basically
understand that it's all going to be
about them the pass rush in a division
where they're going to throw the ball a
lot
uh i think that aldon smith really
sticks out to me in the in that among
that that threesome because look if you
look at yannick and gawkway and and
davey and clowny i mean you know
much ado
about not a lot of production
and with alton smith this is a guy who
really should be celebrated because of
the adversity that he has overcome he
can be an inspiration to so many other
people out there who are dealing with
far lesser adversity or in some cases
greater adversity living in a car a year
before he was playing for the dallas
cowboys a guy who was a dominant
presence for the 49ers 42 sacks in his
first 43 regular season games career
came off the rails in 2013 got his life
back together i think that's the kind of
thing that the nfl really should be
be elevating and
peter i
when he had some some strong
performances last september there was
one week he should have been the nfc
defensive player of the week and i know
that that really isn't a big deal but
the nfl league office decides who
they're gonna be it's a pr function
where they pick these guys he really got
snubbed and i don't know if there was
some hesitation there
to to propping up aldon smith given his
history
but
we should be propping the guy up he's an
inspiration to plenty of others and we
all reach hard times at some point in
our lives and i think it's great to see
him back and
i think they have
an opportunity for him to be really
really good peter if they can get him in
shape because i think that was the
problem last year he wasn't in football
shape you get him in shape he could be
he could be not as disruptive as he was
10 years ago but he could still be
pretty good
the the biggest thing that
and look john schneider and pete carroll
uh have a little bit of of al davis in
him
in that they believe that
veteran players who have something to
prove and really have played well in the
past will come to their place and be
rejuvenated and and i just think last
year late in the year carlos dunlop was
a really good
factor
uh as an outside rusher for for the
seahawks and now they add another one i
just i really love the signing
all right next topic slot receivers who
get discussed in the context of
potential hall of fame enshrinement
heinz ward wes welker julian edelman
which doesn't belong and why
well i'll say that heinz ward doesn't
belong because in my opinion he's far
and away the best candidate for the hall
among those three
um and look they're all they're all
really really good players but
you know look
when you look at the careers
of those guys and you say look heinz
ward was a super bowl mvp had a thousand
catches had 380 more catches than uh
than julian edelman
and the other thing that
you know you've got to take into account
if you're not only looking at the
numbers is that heinz ward is one of the
or the
best blocking wide receiver of all time
and so
when you when you weigh all that guy
caught a thousand balls he was a super
bowl mvp and he was a great blocker and
an unselfish blocker i i mean i'm
surprised we haven't discussed him a lot
in the hall of fame room the day before
the super bowl
yeah a thousand catches more than twice
as many yards
not quite close to twice as many
receiving yards as julian edelman and
heinz ward doesn't get the consideration
here's a question though peter with
edelman
gaining
i don't want to say traction there's
just this hype there's this theory
there's this notion this idea that he
may get in does that actually help heinz
ward because before anyone can ever have
the edelman conversation ward has to be
in
and maybe by scrutinizing edelman people
are going to realize hey why isn't heinz
ward in
no i don't i really don't think that is
very much of a factor mike because
my experience in being in that room just
just my opinion
is that
the five-year waiting period really
is a factor in a lot of cases because
there's a lot of everybody gets pumped
up now thinking about wow julian edelman
a super bowl mvp
second most uh you know receptions in
the playoffs to jerry rice and and you
think of all the good things but
then you have a chance over time to let
the emotions settle down
um and you talk about how it relates to
heinz ward
i think that
people at least my experience is
i think a lot of people have already
made up their mind on heinz ward or else
he would have been discussed by now i
don't think that julian edelman pushes
heinz ward into a period of more
discussion i think there should be
significant discussion on heinz ward but
in my opinion i think a lot of people in
that room have already made up their
minds on heinz ward
completely unscripted and something i
just thought of since it's bill
belichick's 69th birthday and we have no
idea how long he's going to coach
is there a point where someone at the
hall of fame
will say you know what bill belichick
deserves
to enjoy being enshrined in his lifetime
and if he coaches until he's 80 let's
not roll the dice on him making it five
more years let's just put the guy in the
day he retires you think there's any
chance of that happening
i doubt it um
you know the the pro football hall of
fame
made up
new rules for the centennial class
my experience is that
uh with the hall of fame is that i don't
think they like to make rules for
individual people
um and you know who knows the future is
cloudy but i doubt i don't i i just
don't see that happening i also don't
see bill belichick coaching till he's
80. i have no idea how long he'll coach
but
80 is i mean coach in 11 more years
doing anything for 11 more years when
you're 69 is
uh
it's kind of hard to predict
yeah but you know you got warren buffett
rupert murdoch those are the examples
robert kraft gave me four years ago when
he said he'd very much like to see bill
belichick coach into his eighties all
right one more aaron rodgers michael
strahan emmanuel acho players who have
hosted
major programs and ocho had something to
do with the bachelor i don't watch a
bachelor i mean you can attach me to a
lie detector test this isn't a jerry
seinfeld melrose place thing i really
don't watch the bachelor but of the
three which doesn't belong and why
aaron rodgers because in my opinion
uh
somebody
michael strahan
is
does the most wide-ranging stuff
of anybody
you know that i have seen leave the nfl
and go into television he refuses to be
you know pinned down but
like we were talking about earlier in
the program mike
who does
something that is like the ultimate
egghead job here's one of the greatest
football players of all time
and he could be
the substance he could be the heir to
alex trebek
i mean it's just i that
that really
blazes a uh almost a singular trail for
any player leaving the nfl
yeah and it could be the kind of thing
where
[Music]
if he does it long enough and look how
long alex trebek did it if he really is
the guy what will happen is
and i'll call it the irv cross effect
peter because that was the first time i
ever noticed it irv cross who died not
that long ago
when i discovered football in the mid
70s
nfl today appointment viewing
i never knew her of cross played
football now irv cross not nearly the
same level of accomplishment as aaron
rodgers but after a certain period of
time
he's not going to be known as a football
player anymore there's going to be a
whole new cycle you know you're going to
have your anthony edwards who don't know
who alex rodriguez is you're going to
have that whole new generation
they're going to know him only as the
host of jeopardy and and that may be
that may be his destiny to eventually be
known
as host of jeopardy only yeah he used to
he used to play he used to play football
once upon a time
well how about when the executive
producer of the show mike richards we
talked about it earlier says to me and i
quote
aaron could have a better second career
than his first
and that sounds almost like like overly
solicitous and he's being so nice and so
complementary
but
if he's good at jeopardy for 15 years
you know most people in america
will look at jeopardy and being the host
of jeopardy as a greater career
accomplishment than being a quarterback
for the green bay packers i know it's
hard for people who watch this show to
believe that
i believe it's certainly
hey i believe it look the nfl's premier
event every year
every year super bowl biggest event 100
million people watch it 250 million
people don't
in this country
so yeah uh there are other things than
football i hate to admit that
i it's hard for me to say that
it's falderal for me to say that but
it's true
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports